[Música]
y
rusia amenazó con atacar nuevos
objetivos en ucrania si occidente le
entrega sistemas de misiles de largo
alcance el kremlin dijo haber lanzado
ataques en kiev que destruyeron tanques
donados desde el extranjero
jefes de estado y de gobierno se reúnen
desde este lunes en los ángeles eeuu
para una nueva edición de la cumbre de
las américas el evento inicia con
polémica y también con incertidumbre
ante la ausencia de varios mandatarios
hoy se conmemora el día mundial del
medio ambiente y los intentos por
generar conciencia sobre el cuidado del
planeta son cada vez más creativos en
esta edición de noticias conoceremos la
historia de un perro ficticio que ayuda
a su dueño a recoger desechos
reciclables en 7
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva edición
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz empezamos en nigeria
al menos 50 personas murieron entre
ellas muchos niños después de un ataque
contra una iglesia de san francisco en
la ciudad de ovo ubicada en el estado de
hondo al suroeste del país la identidad
y el motivo de los atacantes aún se
desconoce pero el país viene luchando en
contra de una insurgencia islámica luís
muñoz nos trae más detalles
un ataque en plena misa decenas de
personas murieron después de que hombres
armados dispararan y detonaran
explosivos contra la iglesia de san
francisco el gobernador condenó el
suceso
este es un desarrollo inesperado estoy
sorprendido sin embargo dedicaremos
todos los recursos disponibles para
cazar a estos agresores y hacerlos pagar
nunca nos inclinaremos ante las
maquinaciones de elementos despiadados
en nuestra resolución de librar a
nuestro estado de criminales el ataque
tuvo lugar en agua en el estado de hondo
en el suroeste de nigeria todavía no se
ha identificado a los atacantes de un
atentado en una zona pacífica lejos de
los habituales conflictos del país
de hecho la zona más conflictiva está en
el otro extremo de nigeria junto al lago
chad donde tienen presencia grupos
islamistas radicales como boko haram
en el noroeste del país el conflicto es
entre ejército y estado mientras que del
centro al sur la disputas entre pastores
musulmanes y campesinos cristianos estos
enfrentamientos han crecido cerca de
agua también los ataques del grupo que
aboga por la independencia de biafra en
el sureste del país nigeria es el país
más poblado y la mayor economía de
áfrica es rico en petróleo posee 350
grupos étnicos y 500 idiomas el norte
del país con una geografía árida es de
mayoría musulmana el sur selvático es de
mayoría cristiana el hambre el desempleo
la corrupción marcan un conflicto que se
agravó en 2009 desde entonces los datos
nacionales contemplan 35 mil muertos
pero el programa de naciones unidas para
el desarrollo calculó que la cifra
podría ser de más de 350.000
pasamos a ucrania el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski salió
nuevamente de kiev para reunirse con sus
tropas en la región de sap orilla y en
dos ciudades que se encuentran en el
frente de batalla lysychansk y soledad
en la región del donbass por otro lado
el presidente ruso vladimir putin
advirtió que rusia atacaría nuevos
objetivos en territorio ucraniano si las
tropas de este país reciben misiles de
largo alcance esto se produce en medio
de una nueva ofensiva en kiev el domingo
que según el kremlin destruyó tanques
donados desde el extranjero columnas de
humo se elevan sobre la capital
ucraniana las fuerzas rusas lanzaron su
primer ataque contra kiev en más de una
semana se dispararon misiles de largo
alcance desde el mar caspio rusia dice
que su objetivo eran los tanques y
vehículos blindados suministrados por
europa tras los ataques el presidente
ruso vladimir putin lanzó su advertencia
a occidente
si van a ser suministrados los misiles
de largo alcance sacaremos ciertas
conclusiones y utilizaremos nuestros
propios medios de destrucción que
tenemos suficientes para golpear
aquellos objetivos que aún no hemos
golpeado
en la capital se percibía la sensación
de estar volviendo a cierto nivel de
normalidad los bares y cafés abiertos y
la gente nuevamente en las calles sin
embargo algunos residentes estaban
preparados para eventuales bombardeos
todos hemos salido al patio y tercero y
ha cesado estamos acostumbrados a los
nuevos ataques se produce una medida que
se intensifican los combates en el este
del país mientras las fuerzas rusas y
ucranianas están centradas en una feroz
batalla por el control de severodonezk
mientras tanto los ucranianos lograron
una victoria parcial pero significativa
en el este autoridades locales aseguran
que ya controlan la mitad de
severodonezk una de las dos ciudades que
faltan para que los rusos se apoderen de
toda la región de lugansk veamos
es un potencial premio de consolación
aunque difícil de ganar 'rusia redobló
esfuerzos para acabar con los últimos
focos de resistencia en el donbass sus
fuerzas se enfrentaron a los soldados
ucranianos en las calles de las ciudades
estratégicas de cebreros nietes y lizzy
shanks
en general la situación es difícil ahora
severo donny es que es una mera
concentración de acciones de combate
entendemos que el ejército ruso está
lanzando todas sus fuerzas y reservas
las autoridades locales afirman que han
volado los puentes de los alrededores
para cortar las líneas de suministro de
ucrania pero aseguran que a pesar de
ello el ejército logró recapturar partes
de severodonezk pero rusia dice que las
fuerzas ucranianas se están retirando
también hubo ataques con misiles en la
ciudad de soledad en el donbass y un
aeródromo cerca de jarquín y el
ministerio de defensa rusa dijo que
habían derribado un avión de transporte
militar ucraniano cerca de deza mientras
los intensos combates tenían lugar una
fuerte reacción desde kiev tras el
pedido del presidente francés emmanuel
marco el viernes para no humillar a
rusia
a las terribles consecuencias de esta
guerra pueden detenerse en cualquier
momento el ejército ruso puede dejar de
quemar iglesias el ejército ruso puede
dejar de destruir ciudades el ejército
ruso puede dejar de matar niños si una
persona en moscú simplemente da esa
orden y el hecho de que todavía no haya
esa orden es obviamente una humillación
para todo el mundo
mccomb es uno de los pocos líderes
occidentales que ha intentado
repetidamente dialogar con el presidente
ruso a raíz de su creencia de que
francia puede desempeñar un papel
mediador en el conflicto
cambiamos de tema bajo el estigma de ser
un protegido de su antecesor y las
multitudinarias protestas del pasado mes
de enero el presidente de kazajistán
casi y omar toca jeff impulsó una
reforma constitucional que fue votada
este domingo de ser aprobada el proceso
o traería cambios en la dirección del
país aunque algunos expertos consideran
que es sólo una manera de calmar los
ánimos de cambio de la población
rafael pérez nos cuenta más
kazajistán voto este domingo un cambio
constitucional las nuevas leyes tendrán
como objetivo descentralizar el poder en
la ex república soviética
otorgaría más poderes al parlamento
donde habría una representación más
amplia de legaría algunas prerrogativas
del presidente y retiraría a nursultán
nazarbáyev quien fuera el mandatario por
más de 30 años el estatus del líder de
la nación a pesar de la
descentralización el actual mandatario
casi yo mar tube cahier conservaría la
autoridad de nombrar jueces gobernadores
regionales y disolver el parlamento si
lees las enmiendas con cuidado verás que
en realidad no cambian el sistema
político super presidencial lo están
convirtiendo en una visión más ligera
una visión más suave el referendo llega
después de los disturbios que vivió el
país el pasado mes de enero y que
dejaron al menos 230 muertos en este
sentido después de ejercer su voto yomar
tokáyev formuló declaraciones
si insistimos que fue un atentado
terrorista con el fin de socavar el
régimen de gobierno por esto estamos
hablando de responsabilizar sin
exclusión a todos los que tengan algo
que ver con esto ya sea una
participación directa una complicidad
una instigación o la organización según
medios de prensa locales algunos sondeos
dan por aprobadas las reformas los
resultados oficiales se darán a conocer
en la jornada de este lunes en medio del
conflicto ucraniano tokáyev se encuentra
entre la espada y la pared por un lado
quedar en buenos términos con occidente
quien invierte en los recursos naturales
del país
sin ofender a moscú su principal socio
económico y militar
y eeuu se preparan para acoger en los
ángeles una nueva edición de la cumbre
de las américas que dará inicio este
lunes varios jefes de estado y de
gobierno han confirmado su asistencia y
es que la participación de estos líderes
ha sido el tema polémico previo al
encuentro ya que muchos decidieron no ir
en solidaridad con cuba nicaragua y
venezuela cuya presencia ha sido foco de
debates los detalles desde los ángeles
con nuestra enviada especial natalia
cabrera
andrés buenas tardes desde los ángeles
aunque la casa blanca no ha divulgado la
lista oficial de invitados a esta novena
cumbre de las américas hay polémica
alrededor de las asistencias pues la
administración de joe biden había dicho
previamente que era posible que no
invitara a los presidentes de cuba de
venezuela y de nicaragua por no respetar
la carta carta interamericana de
derechos humanos de la oea este es un
mecanismo según el cual todos los países
que integran la organización de estados
américanos deben realizar elecciones
libres y justas y respetar los derechos
humanos tras la posibilidad atrás de que
se conociera la posibilidad de que estos
países no pudieran asistir el presidente
de méxico andrés manuel lópez obrador
dijo que no
asistiría y que enviaría en su lugar al
canciller marcelo ebrad en su lugar a
raíz de este boicot que de alguna manera
inicia el presidente mexicano se sumaron
países como bolivia y honduras e incluso
argentina que en un primer momento dijo
que no iban a asistir luego confirmó
posteriormente que si iba a venir a los
ángeles luego de que la casa blanca
enviará a un delegado a tener
conversaciones con la administración del
presidente alberto fernández alrededor
de esta polémica y en la antesala de la
cumbre aún no se conoce la lista oficial
de los invitados y en temas tan
polémicos y tan cruciales para la región
como son la migración y la recuperación
económica post pandemia no se sabe si
sus principales actores van a estar aquí
en el centro de convenciones
en otras noticias de eeuu el país fue
sacudido este fin de semana por varios
tiroteos uno de ellos fue registrado en
un club nocturno de chattanooga
tennessee donde al menos tres personas
perdieron la vida en la noche del sábado
al domingo solo horas antes se dieron
otros hechos similares uno en phoenix
arizona donde una adolescente falleció y
ocho personas fueron lesionadas en un
centro comercial y otro en una zona de
bares de filadelfia donde tres personas
murieron y otras doce resultaron heridas
la policía de filadelfia reveló nuevos
detalles del incidente
los uniformados observaron a varios
civiles con heridos de bala tirados en
la acera y en la calle los oficiales en
el lugar comenzaron a brindar primeros
auxilios a los heridos observaron a un
hombre desconocido en la esquina
suroeste de salud y américa construir
disparando una pistola contra una gran
multitud en la cuadra 400 del south
street desde aproximadamente media
cuadra de distancia
fue
un acto horrendo e impensable que
sucedió en un lugar de reunión local y
turístico muy popular y que cobró la
vida de tres personas e hirió a otras
doce el presidente de perú pedro
castillo fue llamado a declarar en una
investigación que tiene en contra por
presunta corrupción la fiscalidad
peruana citó al mandatario para el 13 de
junio castillo puede acudir al despacho
fiscal o rendir testimonio desde el
palacio de gobierno el ente investigador
está indagando desde abril las denuncias
de irregularidades en la construcción
del puente tarata en la amazonía del
país la fiscalía considera que existió
una organización criminal ligada al
actual ejecutivo de castillo pero él lo
niega
y hoy se conmemora el día mundial del
medio ambiente pero esta fecha o para
esta fecha a una iniciativa de una
ilustradora convirtió un perro que
recoge desechos reciclables con su dueño
en santiago la capital chilena en el
personaje principal de un cómic que
busca concientizar a los visitantes del
parque metropolitano más grande de chile
para que reciclen y no boten basura
durante sus paseos andrés granadillo nos
cuenta más
en el día mundial del medio ambiente un
perro chileno ayuda a crear conciencia
sobre el reciclaje todo comenzó cuando
el border collie junto con su dueño
empezaron a recoger una y otra vez la
basura que dejan los visitantes de la
mayor zona verde de la capital chilena
una ilustradora tomó la historia de sam
y lo convirtió en un cómic al saberlo
reflejan súper bien el artista quiso él
las ilustraciones logró captar mucho lo
que es de assam y el mensaje mismo del
del instructivo como está plasmado
también es el mensaje y yo siento que es
el correcto porque estos lugares no son
los cuales a los que uno tiene que traer
basura sólo en abril recolectaron 602
mascarillas
585 botellas y 304 latas además de ropa
cascos y envoltorios de comida los
responsables del parque quedaron
impresionados por sam y decidieron
utilizar su imagen en su campaña de
cuidado del parque de visitantes como
sam son
increíbles de ejemplos para que puedan
conocer todos nuestros visitantes y que
puedan seguir su ejemplo y seguir se
línea sólido y no solamente en el
trabajo con la basura y cuidar no dejar
basura en nuestro parque sino que puedan
acompañarnos en esta estructura de
trabajo en esta forma de trabajo en esta
forma de mirar el día a día santiago
buscando ser cada vez más cuidadoso con
el medio ambiente cuidar nuestros
bosques cuidar nuestros parques el
personaje del cómic que es un perro con
capa de superhéroe que ayuda a limpiar
el parque el cómic ha superado las
expectativas en las redes sociales y
gracias a la historia de sam superhéroe
de cuatro patas los vendedores de
bebidas cambiaron los vasos de plástico
por los de vidrio e iniciaron programas
educativos de clasificación de la basura
y terminamos este informativo en bangkok
la capital tailandesa que celebró este
domingo con un desfile colorido la van
gogh bright un evento que no se
realizaba desde hace más de 16 años los
organizadores señalaron que el desfile
servirá para celebrar la diversidad y
también para pedir derechos para el
colectivo lgtb de iq más como poder
cambiar el género de los documentos de
identidad el matrimonio entre personas
del mismo sexo y el fin de la
discriminación con estas imágenes
despedimos este informativo en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]